voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 27 janvier journée
de mobilisation partout en france pour
l'augmentation des salaires défilé
organisé à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats dans la rue plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'employés du privé
fonctionnaires retraités ou bien lycéens
tous interpelle les politiques à moins
de trois mois de la présidentielle dans
un contexte de retour en force de la
question du pouvoir d'achat à
l'augmentation des salaires priorité
numéro un des français vous pouvez vous
aussi répondre sur le conte télégramme
verte et france pour alimenter notre
débat
la question du pouvoir d'achat
directement lié aux factures de gaz et
d'électricité qui n'en finissent plus de
grimper pour contenir la flambée des
prix l'état impose à edf de limiter à 4%
la hausse de ses tarifs une mesure qui
va lui coûter des milliards alors
comment est on en est on arrivé là
quelle est la responsabilité de l'europe
dans cette affaire on en reparle tout de
suite avec j'accepte lire dans son édito
échos
les suites de la crise ukrainienne et
moscou qui accueille froidement le rejet
américain de ces exigences sécuritaires
hier soir les états unis ont
officiellement refusé de mettre fin à
l'élargissement de l'otan ce qui était
une ligne rouge pour la russie vers la
menace moscou de sanctions qui viseront
le gazoduc north stream ii en cas
d'attaqué mais les deux camps garde
ouverte la porte du dialogue les
pourparlers se poursuivent ont
d'ailleurs dans deux semaines à berck
faut-il faire payer les non vaccinés
après christian estrosi mme martin
hirsch évoque à son tour la possibilité
de facturer les soins à ceux qui
refusent la piqûre malgré l'incitation
gouvernementale à se faire vacciner
contre le coc vide en france 8 % des
français n'ont jamais reçu de dos selon
la direction générale de la santé vous
pouvez relire là encore sur notre compte
télégramme débat suivra à 21h
[Musique]
170 rassemblements à travers la france
donc pour demander une augmentation des
salaires mobilisation aujourd'hui à
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats au moment
où le pouvoir d'achat revient en force
dans la campagne présidentielle
cent cinquante mille personnes ont
défilé sur tout le territoire selon les
syndicats 80 dix mille selon le
ministère de l'intérieur notre reporter
hélène masquelier a suivi le cortège
parisien
une marche qui s'est déroulée dans le
calme sans aucun incident à déplorer et
ils étaient nombreux 1 dans ce cortège
avec toutes les professions représentées
le secteur de l'éducation de la santé ou
encore des transports en tout cas ils
étaient tous là pour réclamer une hausse
globale des salaires avec notamment
comme revendications la revalorisation
du smic à 1700 grenet il demande
également à ce que le rsa soit éligible
aux jeunes de moins de 25 ans tous
étaient là en tout cas pour dire qu'ils
se sentent méprisés par le gouvernement
et il y a une certaine colère qui
s'exprime je vous propose d'en écouter
certains d'entre eux c'est quand même
cinq milliards là c'est les
travailleurs/ses les travers qui la
mecque et en même temps tous les
secteurs si les travailleurs qui amène
de l'argent et cet argent là utilisé
autrement que de quelques des épées les
salariés les revendications sont un vrai
statut de fonctionnaires parce que l'on
travaille pour l'éducation nationale un
vrai salaire un temps plein on demande
un recrutement massif d'un et sache on
demande des formations en ce moment nous
parle d'une augmentation du temps de
travail d'une réduction des congés
voilà donc c'est aussi pour être visible
lisible dire que les animateurs sont là
qu'on s'occupe aussi d'enfants on
soutient les enseignants et en même
temps
on va là on a envie d'être visible on a
envie de dire qu'on veut pas travailler
plus pour avoir le même salaire on veut
pas une réduction de congé on veut
plutôt lent versant la mobilisation qui
se fait dans un contexte d'inflation et
de baisse globale du pouvoir d'achat
tandis que plusieurs pays européens tels
que l'allemagne ou encore l'espagne ont
décidé d'une revalorisation du smic ici
en france en tout cas pas de mesures qui
vont dans ce sens pour le moment alors
la mobilisation de cet après midi qui
était donc très suivi visait à faire
réagir l'exécutif à voir s'ils
parviendront à se faire entendre des
manuels macro
et des français on viens de l'entendre
inquiet pour leur pouvoir d'achat avec
le retour de l'inflation alors peut-on
augmenter le salaire minimum en france
les propositions des candidats à la
présidentielle réalisable ou non
augmentation des salaires priorité
numéro un des français on attend vos
réactions sur notre compte télégramme
place à notre débat
et pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec arthur paris ce porte
parole du parti reconquête bonsoir
affaires pas risquent d'être avec nous
en direct
aymeric selmon ce conseiller régional et
rennes en bretagne et enfin alexis
poulain éditorialistes arte france
bonsoir également à tous les deux alors
avant de vous faire réagir un messieurs
je voudrais qu'on jette un coup d'oeil
sur les différentes propositions des
candidats sur la question des salaires
et du pouvoir d'achat regardez jean luc
mélenchon christiane taubira augmenter
le smic un 1400 euros net par mois
analyse anne hidalgo augmentation de 15%
soit 200 m par mois fabien roussel et
yannick jadot smic à 1500 euros nets
eric zemmour arthur paris chez vous
votre candidat 13è mois aux salariés
touchant le smic arnaud montebourg
nicolas dupont aignan augmenter le smic
au minimum de 10 % et enfin valérie
pécresse augmenté de 10% les salaires
sur cinq en sachant qu'il ya eu des
petits rétropédalage sur les modalités
pour valérie pécresse
et aymeric seulement aux airelles vous
excès vos mesures du pouvoir d'achat
principalement autour de la baisse des
taxes sur le carburant à 5,5 mais rien
sur les salaires que répondez vous à
tous ces gens dans la rue aujourd'hui
et bien c'est que vous avez mal lu les
propositions de marine le pen car il y à
une proposition très fort sur les
salaires c'est de permettre aux
employeurs d'augmenter de 10% les
salaires jusqu'à 3 fois le smic et la
part qu'ils augmenteront de salaire ne
sera pas soumise aux charges patronales
donc c'est une mesure très forte qui
permettra de redonner du pouvoir d'achat
en plus effectivement des mesures
concrètes sur le les dépenses
quotidiennes des français passent comme
vous l'avez bien souligné le salaire
n'est malheureusement qu'une dès qu'un
des éléments qui permet aux français de
vivre correctement si les salaires
augmentent mais que les dépenses sont
toujours considérables ce n'est pas
possible de vivre convenablement et la
baisse comme vous l'avez indiqué de 20%
à 5 5 sur la tva sur l'ensemble des
produits énergétiques permettra vraiment
de donner un bol d'air à l'ensemble des
français alors on reproche à eric
zemmour souvent également la faiblesse
va me dire peut-être que j'aie mal lu
programme enfin c'est vrai que c'est
quand même le reproche qui revient
souvent
sur parmi les commentateurs ce n'est pas
vraiment le coeur de votre programme
souvent vous dit-on le pouvoir d'achat
qu'est ce que vous répondez pas
effectivement je réponds quand on a du
mal à comprendre ce reproche j'en veux
pour preuve avec deux symboles forts
eric zemmour qui a été rallié dès le
début par jacqueline moreau et par
benjamin cauchy qui sont deux figures
emblématiques du mouvement des jeunes et
jaune et vous vous demandez gilet jaune
qui était lui-même un mouvement qui
portait ces questions de pouvoir d'achat
et de pressions sur les salaires que
subissent les français donc déjà je vous
réponds une première partie par ce
ralliement symbolique de deux figures du
pouvoir d'achat dans la campagne dans
l'organigramme proche du candidat exe
moore et puis je crois que ça fait quand
même déjà plusieurs semaines et
maintenant plusieurs mois qu'eric
zemmour continue de montrer ses
propositions sur bon nombre de sujets
mais en tout cas c'est un procès qui
correspond pas la réaliser disons que là
vous l'avez énumérer tout à l'heure sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat quelque
chose de très concret le 13ème mois
c'est une baisse de la csg de 20 points
à 5.5 pour tous les salariés gagnant un
salaire jusqu'à 2000 euros net par mois
ça concerne 50 % des salariés français
et ça c'est une augmentation directe
c'est un 13e mois de salaire donc c'est
une augmentation à effet immédiat qui a
eu un impact direct sur la capacité et
sur le pouvoir d'achat des français
voilà une réponse concrète des risées
moi il y en a beaucoup d'autres que je
pourrais énumérer mais en voici une
force symbolique alors on va regarder un
premier message télégramme qui nous
vient
l'instance m il vaut mieux diminuer les
coûts taxes charges et cetera
qu'augmenter les salaires alexis poulain
c'est vrai que pour caricaturer un petit
peu c'est la gauche qui met le paquet en
tout cas sur l'augmentation nette des
salaires et la droite pour résumer
également régulièrement préfère jouer
sur les mécanismes de baisse de
cotisations et de charges
c'est clairement de deux écoles très
différentes le problème de l'école de la
baisse des charges et des cotisations
c'est que c'est une augmentation factice
des salaires puisque ces baisses des
charges c'est moins de services publics
c'est moins de commun et in fine et
c'est des mutuelles qui vont coûter plus
cher c'est c'est finalement des services
publics qui vont coûter plus cher aussi
il faudra trouver des financements donc
et de l'autre côté les caisses de l'état
qui sont déjà massivement d'été depuis
cette crise du coc vie d'un le
gouvernement des belles âmes est accro
n'a fait que creuser la dette pendant
ces deux dernières années trouver les
moyens d'augmenter alors c'est bien sûr
la fin du gel du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires
et puis on ne peut pas décréter de
l'état ne peut pas demander plus
employeurs d'augmenter unilatéralement
tous les salaires d'une façon
obligatoire donc à part le smic c'est là
la seule finalement le salaire minimum
qui est le seul moyen de jouer sur les
salaires les plus bas et puis après il
ya toutes les aides aussi dans le camp
de gauche sur les plus jeunes
soit revalorisation du rsa mais aussi
des primes pour les jeunes étudiants
c'est dans le programme de jean luc
mélenchon est ailleurs donc on voit bien
que ce sujet du pouvoir d'achat il est
arrivé finalement assez tard
dans la campagne personne ne l'attendait
avec l'inflation qui est un vrai sujet
avec l'explosion des coûts de l'énergie
du prix de l'énergie et les candidats
sont en train de se rendre compte que
c'est un thème bien plus important
finalement que la sécurité ou les autres
thèmes qui étaient déjà sur les rails or
aujourd'hui aucun candidat ne se
positionne comme le candidat du pouvoir
d'achat chacun a quelques mesures
essayer de bricoler sans avoir
finalement de la solution et je suis
assez d'accord avec le programme du
rassemblement national de dire il faut
non seulement jouer sur les salaires
mais jouer sur le coût de la vie et ça
c'est extrêmement important donc voir
comment baisser toutes les charges tous
les coûts induits le logement qui est un
des postes de dépenses les plus
importantes pour les ménages aucun
candidat aujourd'hui on a une réflexion
poussée sur le logement or c'est ce qui
fait que beaucoup de gens ont du mal à
joindre les deux bouts soit parce qu'ils
ont un prêt pour payer leur logement
soit parce qu'ils sont locataires et que
là aussi les prix ont explosé donc il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire encore et les
mesures comme vous venez de le dire sont
aujourd'hui de 2 écoles baisser les
charges d'un côté augmenter les salaires
minimums de l'autre avec les la
difficulté de mettre tout ça en place de
manière assez rapide après l'élection
alors de quoi on parle un le salaire
médian net en france il est de 1900 vous
le savez d'ailleurs arthur je vous ai
dit un petit peu en dessous de 1,6 point
en dessous de 2000 euros dont vous avez
mille huit cent cinquante mille cent
mille neuf cent quarante euros nets en
france selon l'insee 1 je vous propose
maintenant de voir le salaire médian
l'échelle de l'europe où se situe la
france vous voyez c'est pas extrêmement
brillants elle est en queue de peloton
15,30 euros bruts par heure c'est après
je vais pas tous les citer il vaut mieux
cité par l'arrière ça ira plus vite
c'est juste avant dernier
avant l'italie donc très mauvais
classement pour pour la france les
revendications sont parfaitement
légitimes connement on explique sa
selon-vous aymeric seulement
je voudrais d'abord réagir à ce que dit
monsieur poulin parce que il ya deux
points qu'il a il a souligné qu'ils me
paraissent intéressants il a dit que le
rôle de l'état n'était pas d'obliger les
employeurs à augmenter les salaires mais
justement la mesure de marine le pen est
incitative c'est dire que le rôle de
l'état n'est effectivement pas d'imposer
une hausse des salaires dans les
entreprises mais d'inciter des patrons à
le faire et là là l'exonération des
charges sur les augmentations jusqu'à
trois fois le spi de 10% est une belle
incitation les deuxième point il a
indiqué qu'aucun candidat n'avait de
proposition sur le logement justement
marine le pen a fait une proposition de
mettre à disposition de tous les couples
de moins de 30 ans un prêt gratuit de
l'état qui permettrait justement
d'accéder à la propriété à un coût
réduit aujourd'hui donc on voit bien que
l'ensemble des mesures de marine le pen
que pour le pouvoir d'achat que ce soit
pour les jeunes pour les salariés pour
le même pour les personnes âgées parce
qu'elle vient de présenter un programme
complet et quelques jours pour les
personnes âgées et le le le pouvoir
d'achat est au coeur du programme de
marine le pen ici je viens même à vos
pensées pardonnez moi ce que vous avez
pas répondu à la question de tout à
l'heure et mis tellement de nature à
rehausser la france dans dans ce tableau
que je viens de vous citer qu on va
peut-être revoir la france vraiment
mauvaise élève sur ce salaire médian en
europe votre tableau ne parlait que du
critère du salaire donc c'est à pau fut
un peu faussé parce qu'il faut pouvoir
le comparer avec les taxes que chaque
pays comparé alors je pense que
malheureusement en ajoutant des taxes ça
serait encore plus grave parce qu'on
voit que les taxes en france sont
souvent très importantes mais baisser
les taxes sur le carburant pc là la tva
à 5,5 en indiquant que les produits
énergétiques sont des produits de
première nécessité ce qui est vrai
aujourd'hui se chauffer conduire sa
voiture
est un produit de première nécessité
donc c'est le package complet qu'il faut
revoir et augmenter le salaire mais sans
forcément très chaud ce pic parce que
monter le spic c'est à dire mettre tout
le monde au smic au final n'est pas la
bonne solution ce qu'il faut c'est
permettre aux entreprises d'augmenter
les salaires est je pense un domaine par
exemple l'éducation où nous avons des
propositions pour vraiment aider les
débutants les jeunes professeurs parce
que là les jeunes professeurs qui sont
souvent dans des zones difficiles il
faut revoir non seulement lundi ce mail
échelons qui permettrait ou au
professeur d'avoir des salaires de
meilleur niveau en début de carrière sur
paris c'est vrai comme aymeric seulement
le disait il faut voir les coups alors
en france on a coutume de le dire et on
le sait le coût de travail et eicher 1
37 40 euros par heure parmi les coulées
les plus chères avec le danemark le
luxembourg et l'allemagne pourtant
l'allemagne envisage un gouvernement de
coalition d'augmenter le smic de 2 25%
ça va vous paraître une aberration dans
votre partie reconquête nom alors je
pense que vous venez de dire c'est que
aujourd'hui on a une problématique entre
sur la question du coût du travail on a
un smic ont en tout cas un salaire de
toute façon un salaire brut qui est
important qui est trop fort pour
l'employeur et un salaire net qui est
trop faible pour le salarié c'est pour
ça que la proposition d'eric zemmour
fait sens sur la question de la baisse
de la csg elle permet de répondre à ces
deux problématiques qui essaie justement
de baisser le coût pour la charge de
l'employeur et d'augmenter la
rémunération à la charge du salarié donc
là c'est quelque chose de concret où on
allait encore une fois la compétitivité
de l'entreprise avec les intérêts du
salarié maintenant je trouve que ce qui
est intéressant pour mettre en
perspective ce qui était dit plus tôt
par messieurs c'est que il faut avoir
une politique de vision globale on
pourrait comparer les mesures pendant 10
15 20 minutes ce qui est important et
c'est ce que dira exercé que le constat
qui fait depuis 40 ans et que la france
était massivement désindustrialisé le
taux de l'industrie aujourd'hui en
france il est passé de 13% quand les
concurrents italiens anglais et
allemands sont restés à plus de 20% on a
une baisse en gros 2 on est passé en
dessous de la barre des 20 % à 13 % en
30 ans cette désindustrialisation à la
cua comme effet des délocalisations donc
des fermetures d'entreprises des
fermetures d usines donc des gens qui se
retrouvent au chômage nécessairement
compte vous retrouver au chômage vous
avez une baisse de votre pouvoir d'achat
ce que vous avez une baisse des salaires
c'est un cercle vicieux baisse de la
compétitivité et c'est le serpent qui se
mord la queue donc sous cette qui sont
là il faut avoir une vision d'ensemble
il faut réindustrialiser la france et
c'est pour ça aussi qu'eric zemmour fait
des propositions fortes avec un grand
mystère d'industrie pour avoir une
vision globale sur les trente prochaines
années moi ce qui m'inquiète notamment
sur la question du front national du
rassemblement sonal quand je les écoute
c'est qu'il propose beaucoup pour
distribuer de l'argent dont on ne sait
pas vraiment d'où il vient donc il ya
beaucoup de propositions pour pour pour
alimenter pour donner il y en a beaucoup
moins pour financer et l'autre
problématique c'est que venant d'un
parti qui a environ 20 millions de
dettes sur les cinq dernières années je
crois je crois que quand on a vocation à
gouverner le pays fêtera aussi en
capacité de gérer son parti et je crois
que sur cette question là on peut aussi
se poser la question la gestion du
budget est la gestion d'un budget
national dans les contraintes
aujourd'hui connaît la france c'est à
dire dans des enjeux européen et mondial
alexis poule a on va on va revoir le
faisait allusion cette hausse des
salaires en europe pour l'année 2022
l'allemagne qui fait fort qui envisage
de plus de 25% sur le smic notamment au
royaume uni + 7 % espagne + 3 6 %
comment ces pays arrive à financer une
telle hausse et pourquoi la france est à
la traîne et le ministre de l'économie
d'ailleurs continue à nous dire par là
une augmentation de salaire ça sera un
frein à la compétitivité finalement
il faut il faut savoir que le salaire
minimum est un des plus élevés en france
donc là on a des pays qui font du
rattrapage qui sont très loin derrière
par rapport à notre smic donc la réalité
c'est que la france est toujours assez
très loin sur la le le salaire minimum
donc c'est juste du rattrapage ces pays
peuvent le faire parce que ils ont une
économie qui fonctionne
avec la balance du commerce extérieur et
et autres nous on n'a pas finalement de
hausse parce que on est déjà bien lotis
en termes de salaire minimum donc c'est
mécanique il ya la question bien sûr du
salaire minimum européen qui revient
assez souvent qu'on n'a pas encore
tranché parce qu'il ya des telles
disparités au sein de l'union européenne
qu'on ne peut pas avoir un salaire qui
serait le même pour tous ça n'aurait
aucun sens même si on a une monnaie
l'euro 1 qui est la même pour tous et
qui a posé quelques problèmes
rappelons-nous la crise grecque donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
la france n'a pas à aujourd'hui à rougir
de ce salaire minimum au contraire et
que les autres partenaires européens
essayent de se mettre à niveau parce
qu'ils sont loin derrière compte tenu de
ce qui est nous le nôtre salaire minimum
passer la parole à aymeric seulement je
voudrais vous faire lire ce nouveau
message télégrammes nicolas augmenter
les salaires ça ne sert à rien mois plus
tard tout augmentera car les grosses
boîtes voudront leur part s'est dit qui
revient assez souvent dans notre pays
également ça vous inspire quoi et
briques salma
c'est le rôle de l'état de contrôler
l'inflation et ça c'est effectivement il
faut avoir des mesures fortes parce
qu'une petite inflation est utile pour
que la société fonctionne correctement
une grosse inflation effectivement si
les salaires augmentent et que le coût
de la vie augmente en parallèle sa
l'augmentation salariale n'aura servi à
rien
certes mais c'est pour ça que les
mesures parions sur les carburants sont
importantes alors vous avez juste
répondre à monsieur pâris quand même qui
me attaque un peu bassement sur les
finances du rassemblement national
oui un parti politique qui participent
aux élections en france a besoin
d'emprunter pour financer ses candidats
et c'est tout à son honneur et vous
verrez que peut-être que dans quelques
années quand votre parti aura plusieurs
années d'existence il en a et s'il
présente des candidats aux élections
locales il aura probablement aussi des
dettes à régler pour financer les
différentes campagnes électorales et
notre parti malheureusement n'a pas de
gros financiers comme monsieur bolloré
d'air ça fait peut-être la différence et
voilà ce que je voulais dire à monsieur
pâris et pour revenir donc au cours de
la vie moi je pense par exemple que la
mesure de ce zemmour de faire payer aux
entreprises la moitié des consommations
de carburant des employés va être un
gros coup sur la tête des heures
d'audience devant et je commence je me
demande bien comment les employeurs
pourront financer cette mesure et je
pense que pour redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux français il vaut mieux
baisser les taxes que faire payer cette
augmentation continuelle malheureuse du
carburant par par les employeurs
bah ça ça m'évoque malheureusement toute
la fibre gauchistes de marine le pen
puisque toute façon aujourd'hui il est
assez difficile pour un observateur
d'être en capacité différencier le tout
être en capacité de différencier le
programme économique de jean-luc
mélenchon et dénis delgo avec celui de
marine le pen ce soit sur la question de
la retraite ou sur la question de tout
financer tout le temps par des baisses
de charges je choisis aussi sur la
question effectivement de la prise en
charge de 50 % des frais de carburant
pour les salariés par les entreprises ça
c'est comme une mesure assez symbolique
ce que tous les français dans les
territoires qui sont obligés de prendre
leur voiture pour aller aux deux sur les
trajets domicile travail ils sont cette
contrainte là c'est que j'ai déjà en
plus cette aide par les entreprises dans
les grandes villes parce qu'elles
prennent en charge des transports en
commun donc je pense que celle ci est
nécessaire et je rebondis aussi je
reconduis juste un point un peu
technique un point après monsieur juste
un point technique sur la question du
poids sur les entreprises jeu vous crois
que vous n'êtes pas censé ignorer que
c'est déductible des charges donc de
toute façon les entreprises qui mettront
cette part du carburant pour les
salariés qui la prendront en charge pour
qui la prendront en charge pour
justement là t'es dur de leur charge
donc l'argument comme quoi c'est un coût
pour les entreprises c'est un argument
faux il suffit de discuter que l'on
prend les ans pour les entrepreneurs
pour qu'ils vous explique que cet
argument ne tient pas donc c'est pour ça
que encore une fois il faut pas tomber
dans l'idéologie politique il faut pas
non plus tomber dans la facilité la
facilité qui diront distribuer des
chèques de 1000 euros 10000 euros
cinquante mille euros ils sont
déconnectés derrière d'un financement de
l'opération
non mais je fais allusion personne ne
l'a vraiment je ne vise personne mais
c'était le cas notamment sur les
candidats de gauche on l'entend depuis
le début il envoie la planche à billets
il en voit l'hélicoptère à monet mais
derrière quand est-ce que vous
finissez pas les seuls mais c'est pour
ça que je dis que ce qui est important
c'est d'avoir des mesures compétitif des
mesures immédiates à effet immédiat que
les français pourront percevoir tout de
suite après élection d examen puisque
elles auront un impact un impact
immédiat mais il faut aussi avoir une
vision sur les vingt trente quarante
cinquante prochaines années à venir sur
les questions d'industrie l'industrie
nucléaire la métallurgie la syrie temps
vous ne devez pas pas les
investissements de ces secteurs là vous
vous retrouverez toujours avec la même
problématique
avant de clore ce débat je voudrais
qu'on s'intéresse à ce qui se passe aux
etats unis parce que ça interpelle le
mouvement s'appelle la grande
résignation regarder the breeze imation
4,5 millions d'américains ont quitté
leur emploi en novembre dernier pourquoi
un ras-le-bol et la quête de sens à leur
travail c'était après le confinement
revalorisation des salaires c'est là que
ça nous intéresse de certaines grandes
ancien salaire minimum de 15 dollars
contre 12 ou 10 et au dernier trimestre
le niveau des bas salaires augmenter de
2 6% alexis poulain ce qui se passe aux
etats unis c'est un finalement inversion
du rapport de forces est ce qu'on peut
imaginer la même chose en france on est
loin du compte pour le moment on est on
est loin du compte et il faut voir que
le marché du travail américain est
beaucoup plus fluide on peux te
retrouver de l'emploi plus facilement
par ce qui fait que il ya souvent de
grandes des missions plutôt que
résignation parce que derrière on peut
aller effectivement trouver un emploi et
qu'on a beaucoup de petits jobs c'est
l'économie du job certains qui ont
plusieurs travail pour pouvoir nourrir
leurs familles ce qui ce qui n'est pas
le cas en france puisqu'on a cdi cdd
enfin tout est encadré a droit du
travail particulier même s'il ya eu la
loi travail évidemment poussé par
emmanuel macron lorsqu'il était ministre
mais on est on est loin de ce fait là ce
qui se passe en revanche c'est que il ya
eu les confinements il ya eu la crise
ducobu qui est passée par là et il ya eu
une perte de sens il une réflexion si
sûr bah finalement c'est quoi la vie et
est ce que je hais ce que ça vaut le
coup de travail et pour quelques dollars
où est ce que je ferais pas mieux
m'organiser autrement trouver autre
chose et c'est sûr qu'il ya un mouvement
de repli à la fois sur la sphère
personnelle mais aussi de moins
d'engagement au sein de la sphère
professionnelle pour ces petits jobs
notamment en disant ça ne sert à ça ne
vaut rien finalement ça ne sert à rien
et là je pense qu'on peut aussi
retrouver un écho peut-être en france
quand on voit notamment chez les jeunes
à une démission ou de le manque d envie
de s'engager au sein de grandes boîtes
du cac 40 par exemple de chercher des
métiers qui font sens donc c'est plus
quelque chose de mondial on va dire qui
a été accéléré je pense par la crise du
comité qui est du domaine de la la
recherche de sens mais ça dépend
vraiment là encore de la structure du
marché du travail en france c'est très
loin c'est pas du tout comparable au
marché du travail américain merci alexis
poulet en proposant à votre chat de
participer au débat parce que je crois
qu'ils ont à
faire c'est sexy annoncé ce sympathique
on l'entendait miauler et on espère
qu'il s'est pas fait mal quand vous
voulez mais chassez 2 2 devant la caméra
merci également aymeric seulement et
arthur paris c'est d'avoir été avec nous
pour heureuse pour ce débat merci et les
français qui veulent donc voir leur
salaires augmenter mais ils veulent
aussi voir les prix à la pompe baisser
et carbure on ne cesse d'atteindre des
records et deviennent un enjeu majeur
dans le pouvoir d'achat les français des
particuliers contraints d'utiliser leur
véhicule pour aller travailler notamment
et qui souffrent de cette envolée
spectaculaire des prix pour parler pour
pallier ces augmentations l'état a mis
en place un chèque inflation 200 euros
mais suffisant nous avons posé est
question
maintenant c'est passé je sais pas du
tout à ces mois par exemple moi mon
plein je mets 10 euros ça dure à peu
près une semaine et pourtant c'est une
sans permis et c'est cher c'est à dire
les 100 euros ça à partir trop vite
c'est impossible c'est cher et pas assez
entre toutes les dépenses ça y va de sa
m'ont dit là j'ai bien les 100 euros
mais si ça continue de dettes au même
prix ou d'augmenter autant
il faudrait ça ou moins tous les mois
quoi pour pouvoir est encore frais des
fois ce serait juste
compliqué c'est compliqué on fait
attention route de moins en moins et
on fait suivre grave quoi
savez le prix du carburant s'en sort
plus ça monte tout le temps en plus vous
savez avec les voitures d'aujourd'hui ça
consomme beaucoup
au revoir c'est trop cher vraiment trop
cher ce n'est pas du tout suffisant mais
voilà qu'est ce que je peux vous dire
d'autre bon si on m'avait un peu plus ce
serait mieux mais bon je pense que c'est
une peine peine perdue non mais 100
euros c'est quoi aujourd'hui par rapport
au coût de la vie
ça rien du tout un plein aujourd'hui ça
va être ça dépend le véhicule
ça peut tomber entre 80 et 100 euros il
faut que j'y aille mais mais c'est
ridicule franchement c'est honteux ouais
non ça ne m'intéresse pas moi ça sert à
rien
bah ça sert à rien parce que de toute
façon ça compensera jamais le prix de
l'essence qui est tellement haut que
même 100 euros c'est rien du tout au
final c'est mon avis après on peut
penser ce qu'on veut et des aides du
gouvernement que des français estiment
donc insuffisant pour contenir les prix
l'état impose aussi edf de limiter à 4%
la hausse de ses tarifs une mesure qui
va lui coûter des milliards alors
comment en est on arrivé là quelle est
la responsabilité de l'europe dans ce
dossier peut-on être à la fois une
entreprise publique est soumise aux lois
du marché on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir seller dit
aux échos
[Musique]
bonsoir aka jean stéphane les
protestations donc un temps de la
direction que des syndicats d'edf devant
la la décision du gouvernement de
plafonner ces tarifs des tonnes mais au
fait qui décide du prix de l'électricité
en france et voilà on l'a bien vu avec
le plafonnement à 4% pour l'instant
c'est encore l'état et ça devrait le
rester en tous les cas jusqu'à 2025 mais
en réalité normalement depuis
l'introduction de la concurrence eh bien
ça devrait être le marché qui définit le
prix le seul problème c'est que ben
voilà l'électricité ça ne se stocke pas
ça n'a pas les caractéristiques d'un
produit normal et donc parler d'un
marché de l'énergie c'est en fait un
abus de langage il n'y a pas de réel
marché sur ces questions là alors donc
parmi ses multiples un distributeur mais
tout d'abord qu'en est-il pendant
j'allais je me précipite et jacques qu
en est il de cette mise en concurrence
tout d'abord bien l'europe qui est
absolument obsédé je dirais parle par
les règles de concurrence a décidé donc
d'ouvrir le marché d'électricité à la
concurrence alors on sait que
l'électricité pour arriver jusqu'aux
consommateurs faut quatre étapes il ya
la production bien entendu il ya le
transport et à la distribution
et il ya la fourniture ce que l'europe a
décidé de privatiser c'est
essentiellement la distribution et la
fourniture maintenant les nouveaux
fournisseurs ça et séné ses fournisseurs
privés eh bien ils sont obligés
d'acheter leur électricité à des grands
producteurs et de la faire transiter
parce que le transport non plus n'est
pas réellement privatiser sur les
réseaux par exemple en france deux
compagnies comme air t e ou aînés disent
qu'ils sont toujours des filiales d'edf
alors parmi ses multiples distributeur
de courant et nous connaissons aucun
produit réellement l'électricité qu'il
vend alors s'il y en a quelques-uns qui
produisent de l'électricité par exemple
les producteurs historiques edf
total energy and gibbons mais c'est vrai
que les 40
distributeurs privés qui sent fort la
majorité et ne produisent rien ils se
contentent d'acheter et très souvent ce
sont des structures qui sont soit très
petit soi même qui sont complètement
virtuel qui n'existe que sur internet le
problème évidemment c'est que ça donne
la main aux grands producteurs
historiques et ça veut dire aussi que
d'une certaine manière et bien ce marché
il reste très virtuel pourquoi virtuel
alors il va rester virtuel pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord le premier et
non c'est évidemment la question des
prix on voit très bien que la
concurrence a fait monter les prix on le
voit en particulier main sur le
graphique il voit d'ailleurs que cette
hausse des prix elle s'est accélérée
depuis l'ouverture à la concurrence par
exemple en moyenne par an avant
l'ouverture à la concurrence les prix
n'augmenter que de 1,2 à 1,4 pour cent
depuis l'ouverture à la concurrence il
augmente autour de 2,2 et probablement
plus si on regarde la dernière période
où on voit bien que la pente est très
très très raide bon si on ajoute à cela
les frais de compteurs ce qu'on appelle
en fait les frais d'installation est
bien c'est de 2,8 par 8% par an que ça
augmente et donc on voit bien qu'il y
avait effectivement une forte
augmentation 1 mais c est ce qu elles
traduisent une envolée de la production
alors et c'est là où justement vous avez
raison de poser le problème en réalité
la production en france se fait à des
coûts relativement faible pour deux
raisons alors on voit sur le graphique
71 % de l'électricité qui est produite
en france ça vient du nucléaire après
vous avez les barrages le secteur
hydraulique 11% donc 82 % au total les
énergies fossiles pétrole gaz charbon ne
représentent que 8% donc le résultat
c'est que normalement nous devrions
avoir des coûts extrêmement faible de
l'énergie sauf que dans ce mécanisme de
concurrence ce qu'impose l'union
européenne c'est que le prix de
l'énergie soit calculée à partir du
kilowattheure dit marginal ce qu'on
appelle la tarification au coût marginal
cette chose qui était inventée en france
au début des années 60 et qu'est ce que
ça veut dire c'est que ce kilowattheure
marginal il est produit essentiellement
dans des centrales à gaz des centrales
au pétrole voir le pire dans des
centrales au charbon dans le cas par
exemple de la halle à nous de la pologne
et il coûte beaucoup plus cher que ce
que coûterait le kilowattheure en
moyenne produits dans des installations
qui sont maintenant je dirais
qu'ils existent depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années et qui sont
complètement amortis et à qui cela
profite est évidemment au grand
producteur historique parce que leurs
coûts de production sont très inférieurs
au coût marginal
d'autant plus que là nous sommes depuis
ces derniers mois dans une situation où
le prix du gaz en particulier mais c'est
vrai pour l'ensemble des hydrocarbures
il monte au plafond donc c on est dans
une situation où les grands producteurs
historiques vont se faire une marge
considérable qu'est ce que ça veut dire
mais ça veut dire en fait qu' on est
dans une situation où ils vont prendre
de l'argent dans la poche du
consommateur
pour d'une certaine manière s'enrichir
et tout ça au nom de la concurrence qui
aurait dû aboutir à une baisse des coûts
on voit bien là l'un cohérence globale
de ce système et c'est donc pour cela
que des f bouillonne alors oui edf
prothèse parce qu'évidemment elle va non
pas perdre de l'argent mais moins gagné
d'argent
si par exemple on avait accepté les 45%
45 % de hausse qui était normalement
prévue par si vous voulez ce système de
concurrence alors il faut toujours
rappeler que l'état se garde ou va
garder jusqu'en 2025 une possibilité
d'user ce qu'on appelle la rer a sur ses
pas et s'est réservé à cette règle a
fait mal comme si ça veut dire
accord réguler sur l'énergie nucléaire
historique on va pas leur ethnie voilà
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que jusqu'en 2025 l'état a le droit
de calais les prix réglementés sur la
base du coût de l'électricité produit
par les centrales nucléaires qui existe
historiquement en france mais on voit
bien que ça ça ça pénalise d'une
certaine manière
edf et puis on voit surtout bien que
cette mesure elle ne va rester que
jusqu'en 2025 qu'est-ce qui se passera
après ça personne ne le sait alors
finalement que dit cette crise ouverte
entre edf et le gouvernement alors cette
crise ouverte elle nous dit trois choses
importantes la première chose c'est que
le gouvernement il se trouve aujourd'hui
piégé par cette situation une situation
dont les différents gouvernements sous
nicolas sarkozy
sous françois hollande sous emmanuel
macron ont pourtant favorisé eu aucun de
ces gouvernement n'a remis en cause le
principe de la concurrence et de la
privatisation dans le domaine de
l'énergie sauf qu'aujourd'hui de quoi se
rendre qu'il combat ils se rendent
compte que pas si on avait facile et
français devait subir une hausse du
tarif de l'électricité 2 45% nous sommes
quand même en année électorale et il ya
de fortes chances que ça ait des
conséquences plutôt néfaste sur la cote
des manuels macron donc ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point ben
c'est aussi que économiquement il voit
très bien qu'il ne peut pas se permettre
ce genre de hausse pourquoi parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d entreprises qui consomment
de l'énergie est confronté à une hausse
des tarifs de 45% et bien un certain
nombre d'entreprises le ministère dit
150 y en a peut-être plus elle ferait
faillite troisième problème que l'on a
passé le consommateur alors le
consommateur d'abord mais il se rend
compte qu'avec la concurrence y payent
plus cher que ce qu'il devrait et puis
surtout le consommateur civet un petit
peu écologique il va se poser une
question comment se fait-il qu'il doit
payer un prix qui correspond à des
centrales à gaz des centrales à charbon
ou des centrales au fioul alors que
l'énergie en france elle est massivement
produite par le nucléaire et par
l'hydraulique de sources d'énergie qui
ne produisent pas de ce2 et qui sont
particulièrement verte donc là aussi il
y à une contradiction flagrante qui
vient de ce processus de mise en
concurrence cette privatisation dans le
domaine de l'électricité et bien merci
nous avoir avertis jacques merci à vous
et à la semaine prochaine pour un nouvel
enclos et commercy
et autres préoccupations en france la
question des retraites pas vraiment au
coeur de la campagne présidentielle pour
l'instant en novembre dernier manuel
macron a relancé le débat sur cet
éventuel report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite le conseil d'orientation des
retraites c'est aujourd'hui pencher sur
la question des études s'interrogent sur
l'impact d'une telle réforme qualifiée
de nécessaire par le chef de l'état
regard
[Musique]
je
tous
vous
[Musique]
montaut
tous
les pourparlers sur la crise ukrainienne
se poursuivant dans deux semaines à
berlin sous le format normandie des
discussions qui ont repris hier à paris
des échanges de jets difficile mais
français allemand russe et ukrainien se
sont entendus pour éviter les scans had
pas d'avancer en revanche entre la
russie les états unis et l'otan moscou a
accueilli froidement aujourd'hui la
réponse de washington de refuser de
mettre fin à son un élargissement de
l'alliance à l'ukraine principales
revendications de la russie les
précisions de notre correspondante
verhaeghe hoffman
la balle est désormais dans le camp
russe l'ambassadeur américain en russie
john salley vannes a remis hier une
réponse écrite aux propositions russes
en matière de sécurité mutuelle une
réponse a été également envoyée par le
secrétaire général de l'otan et un
stoltenberg les deux documents sont
actuellement étudiées conjointement par
la russie selon le chef de la diplomatie
russe sergueï lavrov le document ne
répond pas à la préoccupation centrale
russe la non extension de l'otan vers
l'est mais cela reviendra au président
russe de décider des démarches suivantes
écoutez
le document contient une réaction qui
permet de s'attendre à un début de
conversation sérieuse mais sur des
sujets secondaires
il n'y a pas dans ce document de
réactions positives concernant la
principale question la question
principale c'est notre position claire
concernant le caractère inadmissible
d'une nouvelle extension de l'otan vers
l'est et le déploiement d'armes de
frappe qui pourrait constituer une
menace pour le territoire de la
fédération de russie
pour le porte parole du kremlin dmitri
peskov il n'y a pas de raison d'être
optimiste après les déclarations du
secrétaire d'état américain
blinken et le secrétaire général de
l'otan et un stalker berck écoutez
d'après ce qu'on dit à mon collègue il
est tout à fait clair que pour ce qui
est des catégories principales évoquées
dans ses projets de documents que nous
avons transmis à nos collègues nos idées
n'ont probablement pas été prises en
compte ils n'ont pas manifesté être prêt
à tenir compte de nos préoccupations
mais encore une fois nous n'allons pas
faire de conclusions hâtives il nous
faut du temps pour analyser et pour que
le président formule sa position on
verra comment cela va évoluer
mais très peskov a affirmé que le
président russe devait discuter des
documents monsieur avec ses conseillers
mais en ce qui concerne la réponse russe
il est difficile de dire la date
concrète la russie ne voit pas de raison
de traîner pour donner sa réaction
officielle mais dmitri peskov a rappelé
que la partie américaine a mis en moi
pour répondre aux propositions russes en
matière de sécurité mutuelle là aussi va
également décider s'il rend ou pas sa
réponse publique
le kremlin estime donc que le point de
vue russe n'a pas été pris en compte par
washington alors justement comment se
positionnent les états unis par rapport
à ces négociations sur la crise
ukrainienne on en parle tout de suite
avec notre correspondant à washington
thomas bonnet est bon soir thomas que
peut-on retenir des dernières prises de
paroles côté gouvernement américain
eh bien à l'instant washington assure
que si la russie envahi le cren le
gazoduc north stream 2 ne sera pas
activée voilà pour la dernière prise de
parole en date de la part des autorités
américaines la porte parole de la maison
blanche c'est en réalité présenté devant
la presse il ya quelques instants elle a
évidemment été interrogé sur le dossier
ukrainien d'abord elle nous a appris que
joe biden allait s'entretenir cet après
midi avec son homologue ukrainien il
s'agit du troisième échange entre les
deux hommes dans l'espace de quelques
semaines et puis la question a donc été
posée à james acquis sur la perception à
des autorités américaines de cette
possible invasion de l'ukraine par la
russie écouter la réponse de james et
qui s'était donc il ya quelques instants
premièrement nous encourageons fortement
les ressortissants américains à quitter
l'ukraine parce que nous examinons la
situation de très près et nous ne savons
pas ce que monsieur poutine pourrait
faire nous regardons de près les
dizaines de milliers de troupes russes
qui se trouve à la frontière
deuxièmement nous allons renforcer nos
discussions avec nos partenaires
européens sur le thème de l'insécurité
ainsi qu'avec nos alliés de l'otan dans
la région et les pays frontaliers à
l'ukraine pour déterminer leurs besoins
en matière de sécurité
et puis hier c'est anthony blinken qui
affichait une position de fermeté en
défendant le droit des pays à choisir
leur propre alliance avec le fameux
principe de portes ouvertes au sein de
l'otan alors pour autant selon anthony
blinken la réponse américaine qui a donc
été envoyé aux autres aux autorités
russes offre toutefois une voie
diplomatique pour moscou avec toujours
ces deux options qui sont sur la table
c'est en tout cas ce qu'explique le chef
de la diplomatie américaine ecoutez-le
nous avons clairement fait comprendre la
russie qui a deux voies possibles la
voie diplomatique mais aussi la voie de
la défense et de la dissuasion et que si
la russie choisi l'agression elle
s'expose à d'énormes conséquences et
donc
même si nous sommes engagés dans la
diplomatie
ce qui est mon travail et ma
responsabilité
nous nous sommes résolument préparer si
la russie empreinte l'autre voix celle
de l'agression
alors les etats-unis qui ont également
placées en état d' alerte 8500
militaires et qui vous l'avez entendu
dans la voix de james à qui exhorte les
ressortissants américains à quitter
l'ukraine pour éviter de se trouver dans
une zone de conflit il ya aussi ces
menaces de sanctions répétées très
régulièrement donc par les autorités
américaines mais aussi par la plupart
des grands médias américains ainsi que
par beaucoup de membres de la classe
politique aux états unis dans une forme
d'unanimité et c'est donc dans ce
contexte anthony blinken nous a appris
qu'il allait parler prochainement avec
son homologue russe sergueï lavrov et
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington et pour en parler nous sommes
sur ce plateau avec régis le sommier
grand reporter rt france régis dans ce
contexte ans à gagner des gros fin donc
qui déplore la réponse de washington
mais estime quand même que ça pourrait
être le début d'une conversation
sérieuse il ya le format dormandy de
l'autre côté macro qui rencontre par
téléphone il s'entretient par téléphone
avec bannières poutine demain que
peut-on espérer
aujourd'hui à ce stade comme compromis
il ne fallait pas espérer que d'abord
que là la réponse américaine
comme on donne une réponse en tout cas
ferme et définitif sur la question de
l'otan parce que dans une crise comme ça
les détails sont très importants et les
mots sont très importants des normes
dans la dans une surenchère verbale on
est dans une crise qui est très avancé
diplomatiquement et il fallait pas que
les états unis aient l'air de capituler
mais ce qui est intéressant quand même
et sergueï lavrov l'a souligné c'est les
autres points justement à même si le
comment la pièce centrale et là là là
quand la pièce maîtresse finalement de
cette négociation
n'a pas été honorée enfin en tout cas
les américains non non absolument pas
céder sur la question de l'otan donc là
il ya quand même des choses
intéressantes il ya encore des round de
discussions qui vont se produire ce qui
reste quand même tout tout de même très
inquiétant c'est l'activité militaire
les déplacements de soldats le fait que
beaucoup de pays l'otan le danemark
l'espagne et ses commensaux s'ils
envoient des troupes ou renvoie pas des
troupes mais on voit des du matériel
écueil est toute une agitation qui se
fait et a également des manoeuvres
militaires et des marges manoeuvres
maritimes de l'otan trois porte-avions
méditerranéen italien le lui et ses
straumann pour les états unis et en
prévision le charles de gaulle donc on
est voilà on est de toujours dans une
cette forme de paix armée où chacun
s'agite et montrent qu'il est sérieux ce
qui est plus aussi très embêtant moi je
trouve dans ce genre de crise si cette
crise débouché sur une guerre ce qui est
quand même très dommageable c'est de se
rendre conduit un certain nombre
d'individus
je parle dans notamment qu'il s'agit
dans les médias pour justement appelée
presqu'à la guerre on moi moi ça me
navre parce que je parle de la plupart
des grands médias américains qui n'ont
pas appris leurs leçons et j'appelle ça
une petite musique vous savez c'est
cette petite musique qu'on rappelle à
chaque fois en disant attention comme si
la guerre à les solutionner quelque
chose on l'a vu avec l'afghanistan on
l'a vu avec l'irak on l'a vu encore avec
la libye souvenez vous c'est toujours
les mêmes et c'est toujours le même la
même tonalité
il ya beaucoup de républicains y compris
réponse et aux états unis elle cette
espèce d'unanimisme comme si on n'avait
rien appris de la guerre précédente et
du désastre que ces guerres ont provoqué
que l'ukraine devienne un champ de
bataille c'est un désastre en soi et là
on a quand même des gens qui continuent
malgré tout il ya eu l'exemple irakien
des pays qui ont été anéantis
souvenez-vous delà de la libye
bien sûr sur la base d'un mensonge et
puis sur la libye moi je j'ai été
frappée il ya un an un peu plus d'un an
je me suis rendu à bengazi j'ai vu un
pays qui il n'y a plus rien donc
qu'est-ce que ces interventions
occidentales qui était censé amener la
démocratie qui était sensé
contré une urgence tout à coup il y
avait kadhafi qu'elle est
sacré son peuple avant c'était saddam
hussein qui allait envoyer des missiles
ou avaient des armes de destruction
massive et finalement on se retrouve
dans un moyen-orient qu'on a mis à feu
et à sang est ce qu'on a envie aussi que
l'asie centrale devienne
un champ de ruines voilà alors yahia la
chine dont on entend
parler aujourd'hui plus que jamais à la
diplomatie chinoise qui défend les
préoccupations raisonnable de la russie
concernant sa sécurité appelle également
toutes les parties au calme et à
l'instant washington qui appelle
également pékin a utilisé je cite son
influence sur moscou pour éviter une
invasion de l'ukraine tient la chine qui
qu' il y rentre dans le jeu elle aussi
dans ce dossier ukrainien oui évidemment
il ya un positionnement et la chine voit
peut-être aussi une opportunité une
aubaine d'être peut-être le dealbreaker
dans cette histoire en tout cas on sait
que la chine est très inquiète de part
justement là là là comment le le nouveau
focus américain sur la zone indo
pacifique le retrait d'afghanistan on
était d'ailleurs un d un des premiers
développements c'est à dire pour se
concentrer sur l'extrême orient et sur
ce que les américains appellent le
finalement la menace chinoise notamment
avec la le comment le
l'augmentation considérable des
dernières années du potentiel militaire
notamment de la marine chinoise qui est
temps d un déclin des points clés qui
inquiète le plus les américains mais là
on a voilà on a le problème de cette
crise aussi c'est le risque de poussée
et les envoie bien que les américains
cet appel aux chinois est aussi comme en
plein de sous-entendus parce que le
risque c'est de pousser la russie
justement dans le camp de la chine et là
ça devient beaucoup plus compliqué vous
avez un pays qui est en phase de devenir
la première économie du monde la russie
qui a largement redressé la tête qui a
un potentiel militaire est une des zones
d'influencé qu'ils la retrouvent qu'elle
a retrouvée dans le monde bah oui les
etats-unis ne peuvent plus composer ne
peuvent plus ce n'est plus la vraie ce
qui est très intéressant dans cette
crise aussi c'est le fait que les états
unis ne sont plus le super gendarme du
monde et il le sable ils ne veulent plus
l'être mais la voilà il se retrouve avec
une qu'à une crise avec une crise avec
la russie comme il en avait l'habitude
mais ce n'est plus la plus grande
superficie superpuissance c'est un pays
qui a beaucoup de problèmes c'est un
pays donc président a beaucoup de
problèmes problème inter intérieur qui
n'arrivent pas à faire passer ses
réformes et on sent une certaine
fébrilité de la part des américains dans
cette crise nous peut-être l'idée de
cette surenchère le risque encore aussi
j'y terminerai par ça c'est c'est patent
glav la volonté réelle d'aller en guerre
de la part des uns et des autres c'est
le faire qu'un incident regardez ce
matin il ya cinq que cinq soldats comme
en ukrainien qui ont été abattus par un
un nu craignent un donc un rôle on
connaît pas encore toutes les modalités
mais tout de suite cinq soldats ont été
tués qu'est ce que c'est par la faf et
tout le monde commence à être voilà et
de d'une petite crise comme ça ou d'un
noeud une petite escarmouche peu débouté
peut se terminer en une guerre ouverte
alors le fameux gazoduc north stream 2 1
devient un enjeu dans cette affaire
voilà à l'instant aussi s'il a réussi
envahi l'ukraine le gazoduc nord stream
ii ne sera pas activée assure washington
même son de cloche à berlin on imagine
peut-être qu emmanuel macron va dire la
même chose demain à vladimir poutine
c'est une messe est devenu une monnaie
des changes ce gazoduc déjà il le nord
stream était lui activé on sait très
bien que les allemands sont dépendants
du gaz nous aussi pour une part mais ils
sont aussi dépendants des hydrocarbures
russes et également du charbon donc
l'économie allemande était fortement
orientée vers justement les
hydrocarbures de la russie indirectement
nous aussi on sait aussi que les russes
marron 7 ses immenses réserves de gaz
alors que nous on en a quasiment plus en
europe ce qui avait commencé en
angleterre ou même au danemark oui
complètement tari aujourd'hui donc on
est dépendant de ce gaz on est dépendant
du gaz aussi vendu des pays du maghreb
mais mais principalement voilà il ya 7 7
en jeu et on est d'où je pense ça peut
expliquer la prudence allemande mais
effectivement l'ouverture d'un du second
pipeline est conditionnée à beaucoup de
choses et il devient central dans cette
crise et ça pourrait aussi une manière
pour les choses se calmeront bas
peut-être on l'espère
peut-être que voilà il y aura une
solution à ce niveau là merci beaucoup
originaires apportez votre décryptage et
dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale cette nouvelle fuite de
pétrole au large des côtes péruviennes
elle s'est produite mardi sur un oléoduc
sous-marins et l'accompagnent épinglé
pour cet accident a déjà provoqué une
marée noire mi janvier le ministère de
l'environnement et péruviens décidé de
sanctionner les responsables grâce die à
des kilomètres de côtes souillées par le
mazout depuis près de deux semaines
alors que les spécialistes sont à pied
d'oeuvre pour déterminer les causes de
la précédente marée noire survenue dans
la raffinerie du groupe pétrolier
espagnol repsol une nouvelle fuite de
pétrole d'un volume de 8 baril a eu lieu
ce mercredi lors d'une opération de
maintenance
une fuite moins importante mais en
nouveau scandale environnemental pour la
société repsol le 15 janvier au cours du
déchargement d'antan quercy mille barils
de brut se sont répandus en mer une
catastrophe survenue le même pour que la
puissante éruption volcanique aux îles
tonga qui a provoqué un tsunami dans le
pacifique
au pied du mur les dirigeants de repsol
rejette la responsabilité sur la forte
houle présentes ce jour là mais le
ministère de l'environnement restent
fermes et déterminés à sanctionner les
responsables
et nous sommes inflexible en termes
d'amandes et de processus de sanction et
nous évaluons des sanctions possibles
encore plus importantes qui pourraient
même conduire au gel de l'entreprise
devant les bureaux de repsol et
l'ambassade d'espagne à lima mêmes
revendications de la population
ils devraient prendre leurs
responsabilités payer ce qui doit être
payé que doit-on comprendre que notre
pays devienne un dépotoir qu'il vienne
et fassent ce qu'ils veulent nous en
payons les conséquences avec notre santé
aujourd'hui et pire la mort des animaux
il ne s'agit pas d'une situation isolée
cela se produit depuis des années dans
le pays et personne n'a rien fait cela
se produit dans tout le pérou nous
voulons que repsol prenne ses
responsabilités mais toutes les
compagnies pétrolières y compris petro
pérou et les déversements qui se
produisent constamment en amazonie des
menaces que le gouvernement pourrait
bien mener à exécution ce mercredi le
procureur détaché auprès du ministère de
l'environnement a annoncé que quatre
responsables de repsol chargé d'évaluer
les risques font l'objet d'une enquête
au pérou en actes de pollution est
passible de quatre à sept ans de prison
d'autant que le parquet reproche à
repsol son manque de franchise la
société ayant d'abord fait état d'un
déversement d'environ 27 litres de brut
alors que l' enquête révèle aujourd'hui
que 6000 barils soit près d'un million
de litres auraient fini en mer
selon le gouvernement ces plus de 180
hectares de littoral et 7 113 hectares
d'espacé maritime qui sont désormais
souillés des milliers de poissons et
d'oiseaux marins en sont morts un état
d'urgence environnementale de 90 jours a
été décrété
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la situation sanitaire
en france 8% de la population non
vaccinée et sont dans le collimateur du
directeur général de l'assistance
publique des hôpitaux de paris martin
hirsch qui a posé la question de la
gratuité des soins les concernant alors
faut-il faire payer les non vaccinés on
en déballant quelques semaines
[Musique]
l'actualité économique de la semaine
décryptées par olivier delamarche le rsa
remplit-il ses objectifs non à en croire
un rapport de la cour des comptes
comment voulez-vous avec un peu plus de
500 euros vous en tirez et vous loger et
c'est donc évidemment que c'est pas un
tremplin pour quoi que ce soit je pense
que le dispositif aura et une efficacité
si on est dans une économie réellement
solidaire pour à l'édition 2022 choose
france 21 projets d'investissements ont
été annoncées en france il ya une
contrepartie qu'on va promettre à des
entreprises si elles viennent
s'implanter que d'abord on les embêtera
pas trop sur les licenciements qu'ils
annonceront après et vous aurez une une
déduction fiscale ou des aides pour vous
installer pendant une période donnée
méfiez-vous qu'on l'appelle pas bientôt
loose france aussi
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts nés sur la bbc une surréaliste
et hopitalisé été nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple c'était
une volonté collectés vous le savez pour
moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on sort du pays il est
clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj jones étaient
des valeurs de droite c'était des gens
qui travaillent c'est les gens qui
avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
et
un certain nombre de journalistes eux
semblent s'être octroyé à un pouvoir de
juger un pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens
cherchent et j'ai essayé de trouver des
réponses mais l étrave ainsi jamais à
oger une qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise que je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question a toujours eu un
rôle historique pour le meilleur et pour
le pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était
un petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio on
sait si c'est grave ou si c'est pas
grave plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire faut-il faire payer les non
vaccinés après christian estrosi martin
hirsch évoque à son tour aujourd'hui la
possibilité de facturer les soins ceux
qui refusent la piqûre malgré
l'incitation gouvernementale à se faire
vacciner contre le comité en france oui
% des français n'ont jamais reçu de dos
selon la direction générale de la santé
vous pouvez toujours réagir sur notre
compte télégramme
[Musique]
au québec par exemple les non-vaccinés
pourrait bientôt devoir payer une taxe à
singapour leurs soins médicaux ne sont
plus couverts par l'état en france les
non vaccinés sont eux aussi dans le
collimateur du directeur général de
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
hier martin hirsch a mis les pieds dans
le plat en posant la question de la
gratuité des soins les concernant
nicolas petit
plus de trente mille personnes sont
désormais hospitalisés pour une
infection au co vide en france un
chiffre qui se rapproche du pic
historique du 18 novembre 2020 c'est
dans ce contexte sanitaire tendue que le
directeur général de l'ap-hp a pris
position sur la gratuité des soins pour
les non vaccinés quand un instrument de
prévention gratuit reconnu par la
communauté scientifique comme quelque
chose d'utile et disponible est ce qu'on
y renonçant emporté aucune des
conséquences où est-ce qu'on tend la
main pour soigner mais on dit qu'il n'ya
aucune raison qu'il n'y ait pas de
conséquences alors qu'il y en aura pour
les autres patients qu'on aura du mal à
soigner et qui eux n'y peuvent rien
faire payer les patients non vacciner
dans les hôpitaux parmi les
représentants de la classe politique
l'idée ne convainc pas et pose des
questions d'éthique
martyr je veux faire payer les non
vaccinés pour qu'ils continuent d'être
soigné on laisse crever les pauvres ce
genre de type dans un pays normal serait
limogé sur le champ il ne faut pas
rentrer dans ce type de démarche on a
une stratégie celle de la vaccination
il faut continuer la pédagogie on ne
doit pas distinguer les populations
pourtant cette question de distinction
entre vacciner et non vaccinés n'est pas
nouvelle et a déjà été posée par
d'autres membres de la classe politique
ces dernières semaines
c'est le cas par exemple de sébastien
huyghe lors de l'examen du texte
instaurant le pass vaccinale fin
décembre le député l ère du nord avait
déposé un amendement pour que les soins
médicaux des non vaccinées soit soumis à
une franchise un amendement qui avait
été rejetée le sujet est sensible il les
sans doute encore plus pour les
professionnels de santé dans une tribune
parue dans le jdd andré grimaldi
professeur émérite au chu de la pitié
salpêtrière
avait lui directement renvoyé au serment
d'hippocrate qui donne aux soignants la
responsabilité de décider qui doit être
prioritaire parmi leurs patients pour ne
pas avoir endossé seul ses décisions
andré grimaldi suggère une alternative
pour lui il serait bon je cite deux
conseillers systématiquement toute
personne adulte refusant de se faire
vacciner de rédiger des directives
anticipées pour dire si elles souhaitent
ou non être réanimé en cas de formes
graves de co vide si pour l'heure aucune
proposition faite jusqu'ici n'a été
retenue le débat reste ouvert
alors il est ouvert faut-il faire payer
les non-vaccinés c'est l'objet de notre
face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pourrons parler bruno meyer
ban chef du service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris bon soir
bruno me garbade merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous à vos côtés laurent alexandre
essayiste et chirurgiens bonsoir laurent
alexandre vous retrouve également c'est
donc les polémiques du jour 1 pas la
première fois d'ailleurs à martin hirsch
qui s'interroge sur la gratuité des
soins hospitaliers pour les non vaccinés
explications du patron des hôpitaux de
paris
est il logique de bénéficier des soins
gratuits cantons a refusé pour soi la
vaccination gratuite et qu'on met
doublement en danger les autres on
pouvant les contaminés et en pouvant
prendre une place en soins intensifs
nécessaire pour un autre patient alors
en alexandrie la raison est ce qu'il dit
tout haut ce qu'une majorité de français
vaccinés pour le coup pensent tout bas
oui il ya des gens qu'ils pensent mais
moi personnellement je ne le pense pas
c'est un engrenage dans lequel on ne
doit pas rentrer parce que à ce compte
là il ne fuit ne faudrait pas rembourser
les soins des gens qui ont le sida parce
qu'ils n'ont pas mis de préservatif il
ne faudrait pas remboursé les
chimiothérapies anticancéreuses aux gens
qui ont fumé alors qu'il est ce qu'il
existe des de la nicotine pour
favoriser le sevrage antitabagique donc
aurait t il n'y a pas de limite si l'on
commence à ne pas rembourser les gens
qui ont pris un risque ce d'autant que
pour ce qui concerne la vaccination
ayant beaucoup suivi ce qui se passe sur
les réseaux sociaux je me suis rendu
compte que la responsabilité des gens
qui ne se font pas vacciner n'est pas
totale ils sont manipulés par une bande
d'abrutis de [ __ ] de complotiste anti
vaccins qui sont parfois malheureusement
des médecins qui prétendent que le
vaccin fait des centaines de milliers de
morts il ya des gens qui disent ça sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui sont très
suivis il ya des vidéos qui prétendent
que c'est un génocide qu'organise le
gouvernement avec la vaccination et il y
a des médecins qui participent à ces
vidéos dans certains cas et je ne
citerai pas de noms certains de ces
médecins scélérat sont d'ailleurs
poursuivies par l'ordre des médecins à
l'heure actuelle donc la responsabilité
des gens qui ne se font pas vacciner
n'est pas totale il y a la
responsabilité des complotistes je le
répète qu il malheureusement dans
quelques rares cas sont eux mêmes
médecins qui ont bousillé le client
public et qui ont sincèrement cette peur
aux gens il ya des gens qui ont peur de
mourir en ayant en étant éjecté qui sont
persuadés qu'il y a un grand complot du
gouvernement pour assassiner le peuple
c'est notamment ce que l'on voit sur des
boucles facebook sur des boucles
télégramme et c'est donc c'est très
difficile de mettre toute la
responsabilité sur les non vaccinés vous
avez eu dans votre sujet l'intervention
de filippo philippon fait partie de ces
hommes politiques qui toute la journée
sur twitter critique la vaccination et
qui prétendent qu'elle est extrêmement
dangereuse il y a une responsabilité des
gens comme filippo qui est beaucoup
beaucoup plus importante plus pauvres
gens complètement paniqués qui sur les
réseaux sociaux se sont laissés
convaincre que le gouvernement veut les
tuer à bruno mégarde vous êtes vous
aussi un médecin tout comme l'ex de
laurent alexandre qu'est-ce que vous
évoque une telle proposition elle est
pas nouvelle christian estrosi l'a
repris également à son compte le québec
l'avait fait avant lui singapour a
franchi le pas
renault megane vous entendez
la position en torrent
malheureusement bruno mes gamins dans un
petit problème de connexion avec vous
non mais heureusement
on vous entend pas on va on va continuer
une interview avec laurent alexandre en
espérant que la connexion surface avec
bruno m'égare banal on va regarder tout
de même de quoi on parle qui sont ces
français non vaccinés combien représente
il regarde et 8% de la population ça
veut dire 4 4 millions de personnes 1 9
million
de 50 ans et plus c'est à dire les
populations dites à risque quoique elles
sont encore peut-être plus âgés 8% de la
population pas vacciner c'est ça
représente quoi finalement laurent
alexandre
on sait bien que parmi ces 4 4 millions
il ya des gens jeunes qui sont pas
inquiets il ya des gens qui ont été
convaincues que le vaccin est dangereux
par les salopards qui peuplent les
réseaux sociaux mais il ya aussi
quelques centaines de milliers de gens
très âgés de gens isolés de gens
précaires qui n'ont pas reçu le vaccin
parce qu'on n'est pas allé jusqu'à eux
on a des pays où on a un taux de non
vaccination plus faible parce qu'on a
envoyé des camionnettes dans les
campagnes pour rejoindre les précaires
les gens isolés les gens très âgés en
france on n'a pas suffisamment insisté
pour aider les gens les gens isolés à se
faire vacciner donc en réalité voyez ces
trois public assez hétérogène des jeunes
qui considèrent qu'ils n'ont aucun
risque des gens dont la tête a été
bousillée par quelques complotistes
salopards sur les réseaux sociaux et
puis des gens isolés qu'il faudrait
aller ce n'est pas de la faute et du
coup bon bah voilà cette proposition de
martin hirsch n'a pas lieu d'être parce
que d'une certaine manière et ne seront
pas responsables de leurs choix il ya
aussi peut-être des gens qui n'ont pas
envie de prendre ce risque d'autres
aussi qui se sont fait vacciner malgré
peut-être les risque-tout voilà tout oui
mais quand vous dites le risque la
réalité c'est que le vaccin a
extrêmement peu d'effets secondaires
et donc il ne faut pas il faut pas à
continuer à parler de risque du vaccin
alors plus risque des vaccins est
extrêmement faible les modern art et
puis le kaiser ont sondé vaccin
extrêmement sûre avec extrêmement peu de
risques donc en réalité je pense qu'il
n'est pas raisonnable de ne pas
rembourser les soins des gens qui ne
sont pas ce qu'ils ne sont pas assez
vacciner le plus simple aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est de faire de la pédagogie
il faudrait davantage dire que ce vaccin
est très sûr et entraîne extrêmement peu
d'effets secondaires il faudrait
politiquement combattre sur les réseaux
sociaux
les gens qui critiquent le vaccin et qui
disent des choses fausses sur le vaccin
et qui disent des choses fausses sur la
chloroquine et là dessus je pense qu'on
aurait dû sanctionner le professeur
peron plus vite qu'il a été sanctionné
on la laissait dire des choses
complètement fausses sur les réseaux
sociaux souvenez vous il ya déjà un an
il prétendait que ses collègues avaient
tué déjà vingt-cinq mille patients en en
leur prescrivant pas de la chloroquine
il l'a dit sur les réseaux sociaux il
l'a dit dans les médias et puis
maintenant il faut aider les 1 2 million
de personnes âgées non vaccinés en
allant à leur contact avec les réseaux
sociaux notamment ses dents par les
réseaux sous 2 par les structures
sociales des municipalités notamment
entre donnez-moi l'alexandre on a
récupéré bruno mega man 10 va pouvoir
enfin donner son avis on en est ravi
bruno mégarde alors vous sur cette
rentrer au 10 mai punition que souhaite
martin hirsch en est on disait c'est pas
le seul effectivement
alors écoutez j'ai écouté ce qu'a dit
laurent alexandre et je suis entièrement
d'accord et tout ce qu'il a dit donc je
crois que monsieur hirsch en fait n'a
pas été affirmatif il s'interroge à
haute voix mais pour nous médecins
malheureusement c'est une fausse bonne
idée en fait nous revendiquons qu'il
faut absolument maintenir le droit à
l'accès aux soins de façon égalitaire et
le plus large possible pour tous c'est
une logique de solidarité nationale nous
ne pouvons évidemment pas accepter de se
soigner avec en discriminant un tel tri
qui serait basé sur une histoire
d'argent est totalement inacceptable car
évidemment on voit bien que si ou mettez
un surcoût pour les non vaccinés et bien
il y aurait un obstacle à l'accès à la
qualité de la prise en charge de ces
personnes notamment en situation de
détresse vitale et donc ces personnes
tarderait à venir à l'hôpital demanderez
une sortie anticipée il y aurait
peut-être nécessité de réduire certains
moyens de soin et tout ça évidemment
n'est pas possible pour nous
malheureusement une telle initiative
serait d'abord un obstacle pour moins
aisés et comme l'a très bien expliqué
laurent alexandre des personnes non
vaccinées sont pour beaucoup des
personnes éloignées du système de soins
probablement moins bien ou mal informés
ayant peur du vaccin il faut surtout
évidemment les convaincre il ya une
infime minorité de militants qui joue un
rôle néfaste comme ça a été expliquée
mais pour beaucoup malheureusement ce
sont des personnes crédules déjà ils
paieront cher leur lancement au vaccin
par le risque de devoir être admis en
réanimation pour une assurance
respiratoire aiguë pour le risque de
mourir donc ça me paraît totalement
injustifiée évidemment de leurs frères
pays en plus leurs soins de façon
supplémentaire par rapport au reste de
la population tous les gens ce que cette
promotion de mes quatre ministres
hâtives tout à fait je pensais vraiment
on pensait que l'hôpital n'avait pas les
moyens de traiter tous les patients et
bien créant de nouveaux lits de
réanimation arrêtons de réduire la masse
salariale
formons des infirmiers et des médecins
spécialisés en réanimation et nous
pourrons traiter de façon identique la
totalité des patients qui se présentent
entraînez vous êtes tous les deux
effectivement des défenseurs du vaccin
on le disait sur ces 4 4 millions de
personnes non vaccinées vous pensez pas
que voilà ce sont des irréductibles où
vous l'avez dit peut-être éloigné du
système de santé mais enfin c'est un
petit peu tard on voit que micron nous
le dit tous les jours
résiste à ce vaccin on voit aussi qu'il
n'ya eu non dangerosité de ce virus
heureusement comment allez vous trouver
des arguments vraiment solide
aujourd'hui alors que ils n'ont pas été
entendus avant laurent alexandre
et bien écoutez je pense qu'il ya un
combat politique est un combat de
conviction amené moi-même j'ai eu
beaucoup de menaces de mort sur les
réseaux sociaux où j'ai défendu la
vaccination mais je n'ai pas porté
plainte j'ai été lâche j'ai laissé faire
j'ai laissé couler et je pense que
maintenant il faut pas laisser faire je
pense qu'il vaut mais il faut mener le
combat contre les gens qui abîment
l'opinion publique en racontant des
choses absolument insensé sur la
vaccination ils circulent encore sur les
réseaux sociaux des vidéos qui
expliquent que 100% des bâtis et vont
mourir de la vaccination
ce n'est pas acceptable
donc effectivement les gens qui menace
sur les réseaux sociaux les gens qui
racontent n'importe quoi sur les réseaux
sociaux il faut les combattre
aujourd'hui et c'est un combat de
conviction qu'il faut qu'il faut mener
et nous avons les médecins et la société
civile responsable a été la hache elle a
laissé les gens comme filippo raconter
n'importe quoi depuis des mois des mois
et des mois en considérant que ce
n'était pas grave mais si c'était grave
parce qu'ils y laurent alexandre
finalement ils ont le droit de ces
personnes en sont certainement convaincu
de ce qu'elle avance et elles ont bien
le droit de donner leur opinion on ne
peut pas mentir vous avez des
politiciens extrémistes qui sur les
réseaux sociaux raconte que le vaccin
est d'alger déjà tué des dizaines de
milliers de français ça c'est un
mensonge
c'est faux donc on a le droit d'avoir
l'opinion que l'on souhaite mais on ne
peut pas mentir et raconter des choses
qu'on flotte complotistes est
complètement folle sur les méfaits du
vaccin et les et nous devons combattre
ces ces théories complotistes délirante
même si nous devons respecter toutes les
opinions qui ne sont pas basés sur des
mensonges éhontés bonhomme et gardanne
sur les alternatives maintenant il ya
des médicaments qui qui commence à être
testées mis sur le marché notamment aux
états unis en russie d'ailleurs un spray
nasal vaccinale est ce que ces personnes
justement qui sont réfractaires à la
piqûre à ce que sa peau est une solution
il serait peut-être davantage facile
aisé de les convaincre
alors que vous avez ils ont
effectivement les progrès médicaux
permettent désormais d'envisager non
seulement une amélioration des vaccins
désormais disponible vous avez entendu
que les envahisseurs et moderna vont
mettre au point des nouvelles des
nouveaux vaccins à base d'arn messager
adapté à la souche omicron mais aussi
des pacsés alternatif à des technologies
plus classique qui pourrait - faire peur
à certains enfin il ya bien sûr d'un
autre côté les traitements précoces
efficace contrairement à tous
sur certains terrains qui comme les
permis clinique des seins qui sont
totalement inefficaces devrait
traitement à base d'anticorps
monoclonaux abbas d'antiviraux ont un
intérêt sont désormais disponibles donc
il est vrai que l'arsenal thérapeutique
préventifs et curatifs augmente mais
malgré tout il faut le redire
aujourd'hui il vaut mieux prévenir que
guérir et le mas de la meilleure arme et
le la vaccination avec les deux doses et
la dose de rappel et si évidemment la
couverture vaccinale augmenter et
devenait de 100% eh bien on pourrait
quasiment vivre normalement dès
aujourd'hui le mot de la fin pour vous
laurent alexandre sur ses alter net il
faut vaccin
je suis entièrement d'accord
l'ivermectine est la chloroquine le peu
le protocole raul n'ont aucune
efficacité en revanche maintenant on
commence à avoir des médicaments qui
marche mais ce n'est pas pour ça qu'il
ne faut pas se faire vacciner parce qu'
il vaut beaucoup mieux éviter d'être
malade
éviter de faire des formes graves plutôt
que d'utiliser
ces médicaments qui sont nouveaux pour
lequel on n'a pas un recul encore
parfait donc je partage absolument la
vie de mon de mon collègue merci
beaucoup à tous les deux laurent
alexandre nommé garvan d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france et c'est un
véritable scandale de santé aux états
unis un homme s'est vu refuser une
greffe de coeur car non vaccinés un
sujet qui relance le débat donc de la
vaccination là bas aussi et qui continue
de diviser les américains valentin
carpentier
il fait la une des journaux américains
dj ferguson a 31 ans et souffre d'un
problème cardiaque héréditaire
hospitalisé à boston depuis le 26
novembre dernier le père de famille a
été retiré de la liste des personnes
éligibles à une greffe de coeur promis
de cette liste du brigham and women's
hospital il ya encore quelques semaines
le patient n'est plus éligible à
l'opération car non vaccinés contre le
coc vie 19 une situation alarmante pour
sa famille
monfils a frôlé la mort pour défendre
ses convictions au scan
son coeur s'est tellement détériorée
qu'il ne fonctionne plus de lui-même
interrogé l'hôpital n'a pas tenu à
commenter davantage la situation du
patient mais c'est justifié via un
communiqué pour l'établissement sa non
vaccination pas ce problème car elle
n'utilise pas la survie du patient
d'autant plus que le pays connaît une
pénurie d'organes la grippe peut vous
tuer un recul que vous tuez le coc vide
peut vous tuer les organes sont rares et
ils ne vont pas les distribuer à
quelqu'un qui a peu de chance de vivre
alors que d'autres personnes vaccinées
ont de meilleures chances après
l'opération après une transplantation
racker peu importe votre système
immunitaire est à l'arrêt
un fait divers qui relance le débat de
la vaccination aux états unis si joe
biden tente de l'imposer dans l'ensemble
du pays il doit faire face à une forte
résistance
le gouvernement américain a d'ailleurs
dû retirer ce mardi l'obligation de
vaccination dans les entreprises de plus
de 100 employés suite au veto émis par
la cour suprême
et les cas comme dj ferguson contribuer
à la division et ce n'est pas une
première il y a déjà quelques semaines
des médecins d'un hôpital du minnesota
ont tenté de retirer le respirateur
d'une personne également non vaccinée
elle pas sanitaire purement et
simplement supprimée en catalogne la
région espagnole le juge inefficace face
à omicron et mettra fin à cette mesure
dès demain matin dans certains lieux une
décision qui sont divisé la population
les détails avec clémentine laurent à
barcelone
à partir de ce vendredi les catalans
pourront aller au restaurant à plus de
dix ans georges d'occupation et puis
surtout sans pass sanitaires le
gouvernement régional a décidé
d'abandonner le passe dans la vie
quotidienne et ce quelques jours
seulement après avoir levé la quasi
totalité des autres mesures qui étaient
en vigueur alors il faut rappeler que la
catalogne est l'une des régions les plus
touchées par la sixième vague de kobe 19
dans le pays et les autorités avaient
imposé à la mi-décembre de très
nombreuses restrictions comparé aux
autres régions d'espagne mais depuis
plus d'une semaine le gouvernement
catalan a décidé d'assouplir ces
dernières mesures alors la semaine
dernière il a tout d'abord levé le
couvre-feu et puis à partir de ce
vendredi eh bien les catalans n'auront
plus de limitations aux rassemblements
sociaux il n'y aura plus non plus de
jauge d'occupation dans les lieux
publics comme privés et puis enfin c'est
la fin du pass sanitaires et sur ce
dernier point les barcelonais sont
plutôt partagés mais paraissait perfecto
et
ça me semble parfait pour moi ces
restrictions et est une atteinte aux
droits des gens oui il y à des mesures
préventives à prendre en termes de santé
mais ce n'est pas possible de retirer
des libertés aux gens on peut se tenir à
distance porter le masque ne pas faire
de fait ou de rassemblement mais ce que
je ne comprends pas c'est qu'ils
disaient tu ne peux pas être dans un
restaurant fermé mais il permettait des
concerts avec un certain public ou du
théâtre
le pass and i ter me semble être une
chose importante il faut que tout le
monde puisse certifier qu'il est
vaccinée au final le vaccin c'est
important bien sûr une grande partie de
la population espagnole et déjà
vaccinées la grande majorité alors ça ne
me paraît pas si mal d'avoir retiré les
restrictions
on devrait quand même le maintenir un
peu plus longtemps quand il n'y aura
plus autant d'incidence après un temps
si les choses s'améliorent on pourrait
le retirer mais pas le retirer comme ça
joyeusement d'un jour à l'autre
la raison de ces assouplissements c'est
que la sixième vague ralenti en
catalogne selon le gouvernement même si
le taux d'incidence est toujours élevé
dans la région et bien le nombre de
nouvelles contaminations lui ralenti et
puis surtout les experts estiment que
l'application du pass sanitaire n'a pas
réellement prouvé son efficacité pour
limiter le virus comme l'expliqué serge
dual band sow épidémiologistes la
principale
[Musique]
c'est
la principale raison que l'on évoqué au
début pour l'imposer été principalement
éviter la propagation du virus
lorsqu'une personne infectée entre dans
un endroit relativement fermé cependant
le fait que le variant omikron touche
aussi des vaccinés fait perdre de la
valeur aux pas salutaire donc dans ce
sens on peut considérer qu'il ne
remplissait pas son devoir
sous la voie à noter qu'ici en catalogne
le pass sanitaire n'est pas vaccinale
comme en france c'est à dire que pour
l'obtenir ici il faut être vaccinés ou
avoir eu le coc vides il y a moins de
trois mois ou bien avoir obtenu un test
négatif il faut aussi ajouter que même
si le past and i terre et est
obligatoire ici et bien certains
établissements ne le demandez pas comme
ici à barcelone une partie des
restaurants ne vérifiez pas les passes
sanitaires de leurs clients mais toutes
les mesures n'ont pas été levées pour
autant ici en catalogne le masque reste
d'ailleurs obligatoire dans toute
l'espagne à ce jour et puis les
discothèques de catalogne reste
également fermée est la lutte contre le
vide en russie le pays a débuté la
première phase d'essais cliniques pour
un vaccin nasale une sorte de ce prêt
qui pourrait remplacer des injections à
terme les explications de notre
correspondante maëlys d'extraits à
moscou
nouvelle avancée dans la lutte contre le
coc vite 19 la russie a mis au point un
vaccin nazelle qui pourrait être
efficace également contre le variant
omicron site l institut c'est chez nous
où nous nous trouvons actuellement que
se déroule la première phase des essais
cliniques quelques 400 volontaires
doivent y participer
toute personne adulte âgée de plus de 18
ans peut participer à l'étude pour se
faire au cours des six derniers mois il
ne doit y avoir aucun fait de
vaccination de rappel est évidemment de
maladies à kovy 19
pour recevoir ce vaccin sur la base de
notre université c'est chez neuf il faut
passer un test médical ce test médical
comprend un ensemble de procédures qui
commence par une conversation avec un
médecin et un consentement éclairé que
chaque candidat reçoit et ensuite il ya
un examen médical qui implique une
évaluation complète de l'état physique
du système cardiovasculaire du tractus
gastro intestinal
du système respiratoire et une analyse
de sang du rin ainsi qu'un test pcr
c'est une étude en double aveugle avec
placebo qu'est ce que ça veut dire
en double aveugle ça veut dire que le
médecin et le patient ignore jusqu'au
90e jour ce qui se trouve dans la
composante qui a été introduite dans le
nez et avec placebo ça implique que le
patient peut recevoir les médicaments
qui fait l'objet de l'étude ou le
placebo qui n'est pas efficace
[Musique]
elle fera pas
concernant le ressenti c'est comme un
simple d'esprit qu'on diffuse dans le
nez en ce qui concerne le goût c'est un
peu trop sucré à vrai dire non pas de
mauvaises sensations
[Musique]
je viens de me faire administrer la
première dose du vaccin je me sens très
bien comme si j'avais me dégoûte contre
le rhume je ne ressens pas de mauvaises
sensations pour moi c'est intéressant
parce que je suis une future médecin est
en général le sujet des vaccins
m'intéresse j'aimerais travailler là
dessus dans l'avenir je veux donc être
l'une des premières à connaître cette
expérience là j'attends une des minières
les médecins observent et si tout va
bien et je pense que ce sera le cas
qu'on me laissera rentrer chez moi
après dans dix jours je viendrai passer
le test sanguin pour qu'on puisse
examiner mon état de santé et le nombre
d'anticorps et d'inventer un jour je
viendrai pour une nouvelle vaccination
pour avoir la deuxième
journée importante
conçu par l'institut canal il ya
également à l'origine de scouts nick v
ce vaccin se présente sous la forme d'un
spray pour le nez en avantage non
négligeable pour tous ceux qui n'aiment
pas les piqûres qui plus est
l'introduction du vaccin est indolore et
pourrait ne pas s'accompagner d'effets
secondaires tels que la fièvre résister
actuelle montreront si le remplacer le
vaccin traditionnels ou bien s'il peut
uniquement être utilisé comme d'autres
ont fait l'histoire et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve lundi pour une nouvelle
émission dès 20h d'ici là n'oubliez pas
de réagir sur notre compte télégramme et
l'actualité continue bien évidemment
toute la soirée et tout le week end sur
rt france
[Musique]
on
tous les jours sans faire attention que
tout en dépend c'est l'unité de mesure
de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous parlerons de tout
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
de tous les départements français aucun
n'est peut-être aussi intrigant et
méconnue que ce petit bout de france au
coeur de l'océan indien qu'on appelle
mayotte derrière la carte postale ce
101e département et le plus pauvre de
france voyez à la rivière l'aria tout et
c'est un peu dégueulasse
mais thawadi pkw et l'onudc awashish au
passé unités il me dit il n'ya même pas
de pain donc là j'habite donner une
compote qui est bien sûr être est ce que
vous avez une idée de qui sont ces gens
qui attaquent un lycée
sapa
tu arrives pas ans
[Musique]
mais sakho
[Applaudissements]
veut contenir tout le monde sur l'île
évidemment quand on est assis sur une
poudrière moi je leur jette même pas la
pierre c'est bien de l'accueillir mais
jusqu'à 16 ans ne leur donne de l'espoir
puis à la fin on leur dit quoi non mais
t'as pas de papiers mais écoute
accroche-toi mais j'ai pas de conneries
pour le faucon à la parole hocini mais
est-ce que ce qu'on leur apporte et est
ce que ce système lorsqu'il est bon pour
mayotte gros point d'interrogation
exception française sentiment d'être
oubliés qui sont ces habitants qui
vivent à 8000 kilomètres de l'hexagone
est content il à nous dire entre
grandeur et misère nous sommes allés à
leur rencontre
[Musique]
il
ce
président est monsieur le président je
tiens vous remercier pour avoir accordé
à la chaîne arte votre première
interview pour la presse internationale
en tant que président à les imiter les
camaro à la première question concernera
bien sûr vos impressions personnelles
après la rencontre avec vladimir poutine
watts ainsi que les relations russo
iranienne précise qu'il risque quel est
le niveau de rapprochement entre moscou
et téhéran aujourd'hui pasqua
semaine
au nom d'allah le miséricordieux
je tiens à remercier votre média
je suis très heureux d'être à moscou
massot et d'avoir eu hier et aujourd'hui
aussi des réunions avec des
représentants de haut rang du
gouvernement russe et mme rose et l'inde
h m crawl c'est
lors de la rencontre avec vladimir
poutine
nous avons discuté des relations
bilatérales
ainsi que des questions régionales et
internationales sur les
allées de manière générale choqué avec
cette discussion avec le président russe
les chasser borg je me suis aperçu que
nos positions étaient identiques
elles étaient les mêmes sur de nombreux
sujets
et nous avons des intérêts communs avec
la russie
en plus d'être voisin d'abord la russie
et nous sommes membres d'organisations
régionales et internationales
dharsono nous pouvons coopérer par le
biais de l'organisation de coopération
de shanghai ocs they had
more il y a beaucoup d'opportunités en
russie en iran
et ses opportunités peuvent ouvrir la
voie à une interaction encore plus
avancés sur les questions économiques
dans les domaines de l'acier de la
technologie de l'aérospatiale ainsi que
de la défense et de la sécurité des deux
pays
il ya donc beaucoup de prédisposition au
développement de notre coopération
et compte tenu de la volonté des hauts
responsables des deux pays
tous ces domaines seront développés
d'abord est le terrain pour le
développement de nos relations dans
d'autres domaines est également en train
d'être préparée
mais nos relations avec